foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar lab automation Solutions how to
move from time consuming processes to
efficient workflows
I am Matt Ashton of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by molecular devices to learn more
visit molecular devices.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to not welcome our speakers
Beverly Pappas bio research field
application scientists molecular devices
and Michael Mendelson bioresearch field
application scientist molecular devices
Michael
you may now begin your presentation
hello everyone my name is Michael
Mendelson and I'm a bio research field
application scientist at molecular
devices my colleague Beverly Pappas and
I are here today to speak with you about
how you can move from time-consuming
processes to efficient workflows with
laboratory automation Solutions
before we get started we wanted to
briefly go over the agenda of what will
be discussed in today's webinar
giving you an overview on why a lab
would want to automate their workflow
and give insight into what good what
good automation work cell entails we
will then provide a detailed overview of
the component instruments that can be
integrated into an automated work cell
to give more context into how you can
combine these instruments to automate
your workflow we'll use a common
application the Elisa assay to discuss
how you can build a work cell to
automate portions of or all of the assay
workflow
to bring the webinar together we will
speak about how an automated work cell
can provide a solution for two unique
scenarios and finally we will conclude
with the question and answer session so
please hold your questions until the end
of the presentation
why automate scientific workflows
research today has adopted many
different complex High throughput
workflows to address scientific needs
the complexities associated with High
throughput workflows create demands for
scientists that can be addressed through
automation
by automating a workflow one can address
a multitude of factors that can improve
the overall process address
environmental factors and monitor
production
some benefits of automating a workflow
include increasing the throughput and
efficiency of a specific application
while also decreasing cost per assay
an automated work cell can include
components that provide a high level of
environmental control for assays that
require specific temperatures and gas
conditions
automation also allows for increased
consistency between samples and improved
assay performance by offloading tasks to
strategically defined instruments
this will also serve to reduce human
error associated with scientific
applications while also increasing walk
away time for scientists or the
technician enabling them to perform
other tasks while the automated workflow
is in progress
it's important to remember that not all
automation is the same
different instrument components can be
integrated into an automated work cell
providing specific advantages when
included
when asking the question what is good
automation some factors to be considered
include desired throughput space
utilization the need for environmental
control and the level of human
intervention needed in the application
in general good automation should
increase throughput increase walk away
time reduce human error offer
environmental control improve space
utilization improve worker safety and
provide a full audit Trail as well as
produce high quality data
in the next section we will discuss the
individual components that can be
included in an automated work cell and
the advantages that they provide
we've just spoken about why you would
want to to automate NASA workflow and
what good automation entails in the
coming slides we'll provide you with a
detailed description on the individual
components that make up an automated
work cell and the benefits that each
instrument provides
the robotic arm or plate loader takes
over for the scientists and helps bring
together an automation work cell by
employing processes to move your lab
work to each instrument within the work
cell
when deciding on which robotic arm to
position in the work cell it is
important to consider factors such as
space requirement flexibility of
movement and safety
the s-lab plate Handler is designed as
an entry-level automation solution
designed for multiple applications and
ease of use
it allows the gripper arm to hold
labware in either portrait or landscape
orientation
the s-lab employs its own control and
software that enables this the robotic
arm to work together with the other
instruments in the work cell to complete
an assay workflow
this robotic plate loader can handle up
to 100 standard micro plates without
lids or 80 lidded microplates with an
exchange time as quick as 16 seconds and
a full cycle at approximately 32 seconds
as you will see later on in the webinar
when we present different work cell
configurations the s-lab plate loader is
limited in terms of how you can expand
your work cell in the future and this is
due primarily to the range of the
robotic arm
the next robotic arm will be we will be
presenting provides additional
flexibility for the future due to its
design and features
pf400 robotic arm is a four axis sample
Handler with a micro plate gripper that
is ideal for automation applications
where ease of use space requirements and
safety are critical
these robots are available in three
different height configurations and can
be integrated to a linear rail to
service both single and multi-station
work cells
the gripper allows the robot to handle a
wide variety of micro plate sizes
without needing to change the gripper
tool
the pf-400 robot includes Advanced
safety features that disable the robot
motor power when a minimal unexpected
force is encountered
this feature allows these robots to
operate without safety Shields and bench
top applications
overall if increased throughput and
multi-component work cells are required
then the pf-400 is the robotic arm that
you will want to perform the tasks
normally reserved to the scientists own
hands
in this slide you're seeing a video
example of how the pf-400 moves the
labware throughout a work cell
for assays that do not require
environmental control plate hotels can
be used to store plates required for
your application
one hit plate Hotel provides ambient
temperature storage for up to 20 plates
hotels can be added over time to
accommodate any increased throughput
needs
the play Hotel can hold the lab where
neither landscape or portrait
orientation and can hold any plate type
assays that require a lidded plate can
be done on an automation work cell by
including a lid storage that contains at
least four locations for the removed
lids and one location for the action of
removing the lid
the automation work cell can be trained
to perform lid removal and re-edition of
a lid within your workflow
if your assay requires sealed plates
rather than Lids then a plate sealer and
de-sealer can be integrated into the
work cell
at molecular devices we specialize in
manufacturing industry-leading
microplate readers with a wide range in
portfolio to choose from you have the
flexibility to select a Plate Reader to
achieve your application needs
it's possible to integrate any of the
play readers seen here into an automated
workflow
each reader provides its own unique
advantages
below each reader you will see the read
modes that they can operate Within
some factors that you will want to
consider when choosing a reader include
the read modes it operates within the
applications that you want to conduct in
the present and the future and assay
sensitivity
single mode plate readers can also be
incorporated into automated workflows
the aquamax microplate washer for
molecular devices is a fully
self-contained system configurable for
both 96 and 384 well microplate washing
applications
for biochemical assays the washers are
used to remove any Unbound material and
unwracked unreacted reagents in the
wells of the microplate
for cell-based assays the aquamax has
the option for 96 or 384 well cell wash
head with angled pins that allow gentle
washing of weekly adherent cell types
the aquamax does not require any
external pumps to operate thereby
minimizing its footprint
the 96 and 384 well wash heads can be
installed within seconds without tools
calibration or alignment
the design of the aquamax allows for
aspiration and dispensation of all wells
in a simultaneous fashion leading to
high precision assays and faster
microplate processing without any
mechanical plate indexing or quadrant
processing
with four fluid inlets the aquamax can
operate with two distinct buffers a
cleaning solution and water to rinse the
lines
automated work cells can include
automated incubators that will assist in
providing environmental control
the electronic STX series automated
incubator provides a complete solution
for controlled environmental automated
storage for integration into an
automated work cell
we partner with lyconic as the XTS line
is the most widely used and most
complete solution for controlled
environmental automated storage in
laboratory automation
the relatively small size of the STX
line make them suitable for small scale
integration miniaturized applications
and short or long-term incubation assays
the STX series of incubators offers an
array of climate options that can
accommodate temperatures as high as 70
degrees Celsius and a maximum humidity
of 95 percent
with the lyconic STS X Series barcode
reading is also possible on the
automated incubators
adding liquid handling capabilities to
an automated work cell can serve to
fully automate an assay workflow
the Hamilton microlab star is a flexible
and modular liquid handling platform
that can be changed or upgraded over
time to accommodate changing workflows
an easy to change layout along with the
modular design allows for a broad range
of setups that can include different
microwave formats tube holders
disposable tip stackers reagent troughs
as well as Heating and Cooling modules
the Hamilton star includes a portfolio
of integrated tool options including an
automated plate sealer and incubator
shaker
the pipetting platform can be configured
to accommodate 96 and 384 weld plates
with tip sizes ranging as low as half a
microliter and as high as 5 milliliters
while also including tools to automate
microplate handling tube handling and
decapping
foreign
each component of an automated work cell
has their own software for operation in
a standalone environment
using the apis or application
programming interface of each software
the scheduling software is able to
perform processes for each instrument
and labware storage to run the
designated assay workflow
essentially the scheduling software will
be performing the commands to move a
piece of labware throughout the asset
control and software serves as a central
point of control for an entire work cell
putting together each instrument in a
coherent and easy to Define manner
what you're seeing in the video below is
an assay workflow being set up in the
generic controlling software
once you set up your workstation the
controlling software will handle all the
processes within the workflow
in the next few slides my colleague
Beverly Pappas will provide you with an
overview of a commonly used assay that
we are going to be using as an example
to present some configurable automated
Solutions
in these next few slides we'll review
what an Elisa is and provide a general
overview of a standard Eliza protocol
what is an Elisa and Eliza is an
enzyme-linked immunoabsorbent assay that
is a common application used to quantify
a detectable antigen within a sample
there are many Eliza kits available
commercially that can detect a wide
variety of antigens in different sample
types
a typical always a protocol can take one
to two days to complete Hands-On time
can vary depending on the incubation
times and whether or not certain steps
are automated
such as washing the microwave here is a
general schematic of a typical Elisa
protocol utilizing a plate washer
in this example the researcher will add
an antibody to a coated plate and allow
that plate to incubate for 2 to 24 hours
following this incubation step these
standards and samples are added and
another incubation step will occur which
typically takes one to two hours
after this incubation step the plate can
be washed either by hand or using a
plate washer in this example we are
depicting the aquamax
following the plate washing the
detection antibody is then added and
another washing step occurs
finally the substrate and stop solution
are added to the micro plate
afterwards the plate is ready to be read
by a microplate reader
following reading the plate data
analysis is done in order to quantify
the unknown samples compared to the
standard curve
when assessing 19612 microplane this
protocol and the required Hands-On time
may seem doable however as your
throughput increases this manual
workflow is not scalable in the next
slides we will share different work cell
Solutions and their benefits for
automating your Elisa protocols
thanks Beverly
now that we're familiar with the Eliza
workflow thanks to Beverly's
presentation we will provide you with a
few different work cell configurations
that can be used to automate all of or
portions of an Elisa
creating an automation work cell can be
a piece by piece process for some
have molecular devices we offer
configuration options that each offer
their own benefits in regards to
throughput and walk away time for a
scientist
we can build flexible scalable
future-proof workflows backed by Decades
of consultative expertise to help you
design and Implement work cells that
incorporate industry-leading technology
to achieve your goals
in the next few slides we'll be walking
through a few of these configurations
and their advantages as well as
limitations performing a defined task
such as an Elisa
the first work cell we're going to be
presenting is the single step work cell
the single step automation work cell
employs a multi-mode microplay reader a
microplate washer the MDS lab robot
this configuration is defined as a
single step because the s-lab robot will
serve to move your labware from its
Hotel storage to the aquamax from
microplate washing and then back to the
microplate reader to collect the data
this setup allows also allows for easy
access to the injector port on Dual
injector capable plate readers
the single step work cell will use the
s-lab controlling software to run
through the workflow
within the utilizer workflow using the
single step will still require human
intervention
as you can see the Elisa workflow will
call the scientist or the technician to
add the sample antibody and substrate
into the microplate manually during the
Elisa workflow
the single step system will serve to
move the plate from the hotel to the
washer then back to the hotel so the
scientist OR technician can perform the
addition of antibody
after the scientists OR technician
stores the lab work back into the play
Hotel the s-lab robot will move the
plate to the microplate washer for its
second moth
the scientist OR technician will have to
manually add the substrate to the
labware before placing it back in the
hotel so that the robot can shuttle the
plates into the microplate reader for
data collection
this work cell does not offer much room
for the addition of other instruments
over time primarily due to the reach of
the robotic arm
for this reason we're going to be
presenting another work cell in the next
slide that is a little bit more amenable
to additions in the future
the next work cell we're going to be
presenting is the future proof advanced
work cell
this work cell employs a multi-mode
microplate reader a microplate washer
two 20 ambient storage plate hotels
a lid hotel with a d lid station and a
P400 robotic arm
this configuration will use the generic
control and software to build and
operate the assay workflow
contrary to the single step work cell
the advanced work cell is compatible
with lidded microplates
with the increased flexibility provided
by the pf-400 robotic arm this work cell
is amenable to further integration over
time through the addition of
environmental control increased
throughput by adding more plate hotels
and the addition of liquid handling
capabilities
the advanced workflow configuration
requires a similar amount of human
intervention to the single step work
cell
the scientist OR technician will still
have to manually perform the separate
editions of sample antibody and
substrate while the pf-400 robotic arm
shuttles plates from the ambient plate
Hotel storage to the aquamax microplate
washer and to the spectromax multimodo
microplate reader over time
this work cell can be used as a primary
starting point and be used to build on
more information instrumentation over
time to provide a fully automated walk
away solution
the next example is another
configuration but also it's going to be
an example of how you could add to the
advanced work cell by including
environmental control
the work cell we're presenting in this
slide is the advanced two-step EC or
environmental control work cell
this work cell employs a multi-mode
microplate reader a microplate washer
two 20 ambient storage plate hotels a
lit hotel and delid station a port
pf400 robotic arm and a liconic sdx
series automated incubator
compared to the advanced work cell
configuration presented in the last
Slide the advanced two-step
environmental control work cell provides
additional flexibility for cell-based
assays and bioassays that may require
specific temperature or humidity
conditions
this configuration is dynamic in that
more throughput and instrumentation can
be integrated over time
the advanced environmental workflow
configuration requires a similar amount
of human intervention to the previously
mentioned work cells
the scientists OR technician will sought
to manually perform the separate
editions of sample antibody and
substrate while the pf-400
robotic arm shuttles plates from the
ambient plates Hotel storage to the
aquamax microplate washer and spectromax
multi-mode microplay reader
the major change in the workflow comes
with the addition of an automated
incubator
the iconic sdx automated incubator
allows the work cell to accommodate
cell-based assays and bioassays that may
require a defined level of environmental
control
in this case the automated incubator
will house the plates and transfer them
to the pf-400 robotic arm which will
then shuttle them to each of the other
instruments within the work cell
the next two work cells that we will be
presenting offer significantly increased
walkaway time due to the inclusion of a
dedicated liquid Handler to the work
cell
the high throughput screening or HTS
environmental control work cell includes
a multi-mode microflate reader a
microplate washer the pf-400 robotic arm
iconic STX series incubator and a
Hamilton star automated liquid Handler
the addition of liquid handling
capabilities allows for automated sample
and reagent handling resulting in a
reduction in human error and vastly
increased walkaway time in comparison to
the already presented work cells
the iconic automated incubator also
provides this work cell with
environmental control to handle
cell-based and biological assays that
require specific temperatures or
humidity levels
this this works out as Limited in
throughput by the amount of storage
available within the automated incubator
foreign
as you can see in the workflow image
above in the context of an Elisa where
low volume reagent additions are
required the scientist OR technician is
only needed to begin the workflow
once the plate is placed in the
automated incubator for storage the
Hamilton automated liquid Handler will
take the plates and perform the
additions of sample antibody and
substrate while also shoveling the
plates to the aquamax for Unbound
material and unselected reagents in the
wells will be washed away by before
reading the microplate on the spectromax
multi-mode microplate reader
the final configuration for automating
an Elisa workflow that we will present
is the fully automated multiple step
high throughput screening work cell
like the high throughput work cell just
presented this work cell allows for
analyzer to be fully automated from
start to finish
this work cell includes a spectrum X
multi-mode micro Plate Reader aquamax
microplate washer
for 20 ambient plate Hotel storage a lid
hotel with Dillard station a P400 Rover
pf400 robot Hamilton liquid Handler and
the lyconic STX automated incubator
this work cell can accommodate more
throughput than any we have prevented
thus far while also allowing for
increased throughput over time through
the addition of the addition of more
plate hotels
this configuration is the most complete
work cell presented thus far providing a
complete walkaway solution with
increased throughput and assay
flexibility
putting it all together the htsx
multiple step work cell provides you
with a complete walkaway solution for an
Elisa workflow
the scientist OR technician is only
needed to begin the workflow once the
plate is placed in automated incubator
for storage the Hamilton automated
liquid Handler will take plates and
perform the additions of sample antibody
and substrate while also shuttling
plates to the aquamax for Unbound
material and unreactive reagents in the
wells will be washed away before reading
the microplate on the microplate reader
the plate hotels in this scenario can
increase capacity by allowing for
storage of up to 80 plates within the
plate hotels
additional to the storage that would
occur within the automated incubator
during the next section of the webinar
my colleague Beverly Pappas will present
a few scenarios and take you through how
the assay workflow is presented in the
scenarios can be automated by the
instrumentation prevented thus far
outside of these existing work cells
molecular devices also offers
customizable solutions for other
applications or workflows these next few
slides will highlight unique Eliza
custom options please note that we also
have work cell solutions for other
assays if you're interested in learning
more please reach out
here is an example in which the customer
already has a molecular devices Plate
Reader and washer they are now
interested in automating their workflow
to decrease Hands-On time and increase
their throughput for this customer the
Eliza HTS X work cell will meet their
needs and can easily be integrated with
their existing Plate Reader and washer
this custom solution will include a
liquid Handler capable of loading their
samples and assay reagents plate hotels
and a robotic arm removing the plates to
the designated instruments these
additional instruments will enable the
customer to have a complete walk away
solution
in this example the customer is running
an IGG Elisa asset using 96 well plates
the customer plans to have researchers
load samples and would like to automate
the workflow Downstream of this sample
Edition specifically they would like to
automate the addition of asset Solutions
plate ceiling and removal pre and post
incubation steps plate washing and
reading the plate
since the customer will be automating
the steps Downstream of sample Edition a
larger liquid Handler is not needed
instead a custom work cell has been
designed this work cell includes a
reagent dispenser in which the end user
will be able to add unique solutions for
the protocol a plate sealer and peeler
for adding and removal of plate seals
respectively an aquamax plate washer for
washing their plates and an and an
absorbently reader plate hotels are
added for the customer's specified
capacity and a robotic arm for moving
the plates to the designated instruments
this concludes our presentation on how
you can move from time consuming
processes to efficient workflows with
laboratory automation Solutions
if you're interested in learning more
please reach out to myself or Michael
via email thank you
thank you Beverly and Michael for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar with Beverly if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay let's get started Beverly here is
the first question
if we decide to purchase Just A Plate
Reader are we able to add components and
create an automated work cell over time
but I think you might be muted here
see if we can get that fixed
see let's try to yeah we still can't
hear you
um
still cannot
so it does look like
we do we are having some technical
difficulties
on your end
let's see if we can hear you now I'm
gonna try it again Beverly
oh there we go okay we're back okay uh
thanks for bearing with us let's uh
let's restart from question one uh you
can response after I read it
if we decide to purchase Just A Plate
Reader are we able to add components and
create an automated work cell over time
definitely so as we saw um in the
presentation with the first customer
example if you're just interested in
getting a Plate Reader right now and
then you plan to move forward or in the
future
um want to do automation we're
definitely a company that can grow with
your lab
okay thank you
uh question two
is it possible to have an automated
solution that can cover multiple
applications yes it definitely can so I
know in the presentation we featured
Eliza's but there definitely are options
in order to cover different workflows as
you start to expand your work cell to
include these different workflows please
reach out to us so that way we can make
sure you have the right equipment as
well as the scheduling software is able
to handle these new steps that may be
incorporated with the different assays
okay thank you
question number three can we integrate
instruments from other vendors that were
not mentioned in this webinar to a work
cell
it is possible we would need to know the
specific instrument as well as if there
are specific drivers that are able to be
integrated with our scheduling software
that we mentioned in the presentation
but that's a conversation that you can
have with our workflow Solutions team
that will be able to further assist and
be able to let you know if that's
possible
okay and now it looks like we have time
for just one more question here
uh what is the next step if I'm ready to
move forward with an automated solution
yes as you can see on the screen feel
free to reach out to us either at info
moldev.com alternatively you can reach
out to myself or Michael via email and
we'll be able to connect you with our
automation workflow specialist to be
able to begin those conversations
perfect thank you Beverly
and lastly do you have any final
comments for our audience here today
it was great interacting with you all
today please again if you have any
questions about automation or making
your workflows more robust and
scalability please again reach out to us
either at info moldef.com or myself or
Michael via our emails it's our first
theme period our last name at moldev.com
and can't wait to hear from you
okay perfect looks like it wraps it up
uh we wanted to say thank you again
Beverly for your time and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor molecular devices
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
your interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker of the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye